à moscou elle appelle au respect des
accords de minsk et qui prévoit un
cessez le feu dans le donbass notre
envoyé spécial antoine gayraud y est
allé à donner à ce qui est plus
précisément lieu où les combats font
rage depuis le début du conflit
je me trouve maintenant dans le quartier
de l'aéroport de deux nièces que
l'aéroport qui se trouve juste ici sur
ma gauche théâtre des combats parmi les
plus violents les plus sanglants en
particulier au début du conflit je vous
propose d'aller à la rencontre d'un des
derniers habitants de ce quartier qui
continuent de vivre ici et ce malgré les
bombardements quasi quotidiens
il est à des tirs tout le temps tous les
jours ils tirent sur l'aéroport autour
sur spartak le village d'à côté personne
ne vit ici
ma fille m'a dit de déménager dans leur
appartement et je lui ai répondu que je
ne quitterai jamais ma maison je les
construite moi même je ne la quitterai
jamais l'aéroport john yates qui a été
l'objet de batailles féroces entre
soldats ukrainien et combattant du nom
base durant une bonne partie de l'année
2014 en particulier en automne et en
hiver les bâtiments de l'aéroport ont
été réduits à l'état de ruines
tout comme la plupart des habitations
alentour nicolaï qui est en quelque
sorte à la mémoire vivante des habitants
de ce quartier nous a raconté ce qu'il
est advenu de la maison de ses voisins
cette maison a été touchée par deux
missiles grad
à l'intérieur ça a pris feu deux
missiles ont explosé
c'est un voisin qui vivaient ici mais
son coeur a lâché pendant les
bombardements
il est mort il ne reste plus une seule
maison inde m c'est la croix rouge qui a
réparé montois le toit et le plafond
avait été cassée 14 missiles ont
transpercé dans la grange les colombiers
ont été rasés j'ai eu des dents cassées
ce quartier quasiment à l'abandon
maintenant depuis de nombreuses années
reste néanmoins très dangereux en plus
des bombardements quasi quotidiens
il faut sans cesse regarder où l'on met
les pieds de risque de marcher sur une
munition sur une grenade qui n'a pas
encore explosé